today on the matt walsh show cancel
culture claims another victim this time
a random woman at a dog park has her
whole life destroyed after an out of
context video goes viral also liz cheney
comes out for trans rights biden tells
blatant lies about border patrol and the
media wonders why so many people with
coveted symptoms are testing negative
for the virus i have a theory about that
plus the loudoun county school board
tried to stop me from speaking at their
next meeting by changing the rules but i
may have found a workaround and in our
daily cancellation we will cancel the
female james bond before she even exists
all of that and more today on the matt
wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before we get started today uh just a
reminder that if you are watching this
on youtube the best thing that you can
do
for
me personally and and in some ways for
yourself in your own life is to hit
like and also subscribe and the more
that you like and the more that you
comment uh the more that it will fool
the algorithm into thinking that i'm
more popular than i really am and that
really is the the goal here so make sure
to hit like do it right now do it now
uh it also is if you're on youtube while
you're there you might as well go check
out the other content that we have on
the channel we put up content every
single day
and this saturday we put up um
the first and what will probably be
unfortunately a series uh what we're
calling the adventure series where i go
places against my will i'm sent to
places um and i have to try to have a
good time this time uh me and and uh
knowles were sent to uh a uh an escape
room and i didn't know that's where they
were saying they put us in a car and
they there was cameras rigged and they
said just go to this address and we got
there
and uh
our worst nightmares were realized and
it was an escape room and we did a
horrible job of escaping i put all the
blame on michael knowles because as i
share in that video i did do an escape
room with ben shapiro years ago
and we got out we escaped quickly
mainly because it was all been doing all
the work
so i have to rely on other people to do
the work just like back in high school
you know i if in a group assignment i
was always the guy sitting there while
everyone else does everything so anyway
go check out that video and all the
other content that we have okay um
you know i can remember speaking of
being in high school
the bullies that i went to school with
you know the real life schoolyard bully
was never quite as one-dimensional and
cartoonishly villainous as he was
portrayed in shows and movies that we
watched back then but he was still a
jerk right and as i recall bullies were
pretty straightforward they would impose
themselves on those who are weaker and
taunt and belittle them
because it gave them the bullies
personal satisfaction and probably
because they were trying to assuage
their own damaged egos and enhance their
own sense of self-worth and so on
but the message from the bully was
i'm strong you're weak
and that makes me better than you
the bully would try to hurt his victim's
feelings or hurt him physically and if
he succeeded then he won at least in his
mind
that's why the best response to a bully
back then was to try to beat him at his
own game to cause him the exact sort of
hurt that he wanted to cause you if you
succeeded then the bully was vanquished
at least for a time if you punched the
bully in the nose and made him run off
crying
then you won because you had asserted
your dominance over him
he had made a fool of himself and cried
in front of everybody and this was a
source of shame
that's the way that it used to work it
wasn't it wasn't great
it wasn't a great position to be in
bullying is never a good thing it was a
little bit messy at times
but i have to say lately i've been
pining for the simplicity and the
coherence of those days
how bullying used to work
because now things are flipped on their
head
the bullies are all
you know sort of modeling themselves
after that scene and fight club where uh
edward norton gets revenge on his boss
by beating the hell out of himself in
the boss's office
so the bully now asserts his dominance
assuages his ego
enhances his own self-worth
by manufacturing ways in which he has
been hurt by his victim
bullying today is far more
passive-aggressive
manipulative
and psychologically twisted than the
simple days of you know calling somebody
a name shoving them into a locker to let
them know that you're more powerful than
them
now the bullies assert their power
by pretending that their victim is
asserting power over them they gain
power by affecting powerlessness
when i was younger it would have been
embarrassing for anyone especially a guy
to admit that he had his feelings hurt
now there's a contest over who had their
feelings hurt the most
you know it used to be if you said i got
my feelings hurt everybody would point
and laugh at you you got your feelings
hurt you loser
now instead of responding that way
everybody says no no i have my feelings
hurt even more than you
neither response is great
but what we're doing now is worse
this is how modern cancer culture works
of course
we saw a perfect example of this over
the weekend when a guy by the name of
frederick joseph who's a black man and
also an author and i'll tell you more
about his book in a moment because it is
relevant here
he sent out a string of tweets claiming
that he had been accosted by a white
woman in a dog park in brooklyn he
tweeted quote at the dog park in
brooklyn with my fiance and this white
woman was threatening to call police and
told us to stay in our hood because she
had our dog confused with another dog
who had been barking loudly
so i started recording and she tried to
slap the phone out of my hand
he then posted the video of course but
but naturally the video cuts on right
after all of this allegedly happened
let's watch it here check it out
no no no no no no no no no everyone stay
in
our stay in our hood that's what i'm
sorry what
stay in our hood
stay in our hood you just told us to
stay in our hood you just told us to
leave the dog and stay in our hood oh my
god did you just say that's me
wow that's funny
i'm sorry you were right here watch this
entire thing did she just not stand here
tell us to stay in our hood she did she
just you just told us
so what do we know from that video um
well nothing at all we don't know the
context we don't know what was said
before the video cuts on
we don't know what precipitated the
interaction or even what the interaction
was
we don't know if she said what he
claimed she said or why she said it if
she did if she did in fact say anything
we don't know anything
we have only this out of context video
featuring a group of people that none of
us have ever heard of
and we have the word of mr frederick
joseph
a word which
must be taken with a rather large
portion of salt given that frederick
joseph is the author of a book called
the black friend on being a better white
person
on being a better white person
now i don't need to read the book to
know that it's a racist screed for the
same reason that frederick joseph
wouldn't have to read a book by me about
being a better black person to declare
that it's racist
so this guy's a professional race baiter
who's in the business of telling white
people how to be better and he just so
happens to find himself
in this situation with an allegedly
racist white woman
you might almost think that this
anti-white race-baiting bigot may have
engineered this situation to play out
exactly as it did who knows
but joseph wasn't satisfied to simply
put the video up and leave it at that of
course he then proceeds to dig up this
woman's name
and other pictures of her and post them
online also
he even posts the name of her dog for
some reason
he uh posts the the town where she lives
and then he finds out where she works
or worked i should say and he posts that
information and then he personally
contacts her boss by the name of derrick
anderson at a company called bevy to try
and get her fired
and obviously he succeeds
so within hours of the original out of
context 15 second video being posted
the woman has lost her job
lost her reputation
her privacy
probably most of her friends given where
she lives
derek anderson her former boss tweeted
this
bevy has zero tolerance for
discriminatory behavior of any kind
yesterday an employee engaged in
behavior contrary to our values and has
been terminated we apologized deeply to
all involved
now how does he know what sort of
behavior she engaged in
there couldn't have been enough time to
actually investigate the situation
thoroughly
we don't know
but that doesn't matter all he knows is
that frederick joseph
says that his feelings were hurt and
that's all the information he needs
now for his part for his part after
randomly ruining this stranger's life
for no reason
frederick joseph posted a follow-up
video encouraging everybody white people
namely to uh learn the right lessons
from this incident watch this
so i was just told
that bevy
has terminated emma sarley after her
racist attack against my fiance and i in
the dog park and while it's unfortunate
um that she had to lose her job um i do
think that this brings up an important
conversation about
accountability
especially in a country where um black
and brown people uh marginalized people
as a whole
have seen so little of it um often times
right um you know having to bear the
burden of racism sexism homophobia et
cetera
i think that it's important that people
know that there are consequences uh for
their actions right and i don't think
that it's
up to victims to have to coddle um you
know people who are engaging in abuse
um you know when i woke up yesterday
morning um i didn't expect to have to be
a part of this um conversation um i
didn't expect to go to the dog park as a
black person um and
have to receive um you know racism uh
you know so while again it is
unfortunate what happened i hope that
you know emma learns from this i hope
that um other people learn from this who
engage in abusive racist um and
destructive behavior because ultimately
um whether emma lost her job or not
doesn't take away the trauma that my
fiance and i have it doesn't take away
um the feeling of
feeling like anything
racist can happen anywhere so
i don't think that people should be
coddled and i do think that consequences
are important so hopefully this is a
learning lesson for everybody
a learning lesson
so the rule maintains here the rule i've
told you about anytime someone says
they've done or said something in order
to start a conversation
they're always full of it 100 of the
time
and here yet again well it brings up an
important conversation it's unfortunate
she had to lose her job she had to lose
her job it's unfortunate
after i have deliberately
made sure that she loses her job after i
spent my weekend
trying to make sure that this woman lost
her job
it's unfortunate that it happened it had
to happen
it's just how the stars aligned you know
it's fate what could i do about it
well it turns out i could do a lot to
make sure she loses her job because
that's what i spent my weekend doing
he says he was traumatized
he's traumatized by this uh little white
woman at a dog park
when
when i was a kid
you know if a guy had had claimed to
have been traumatized
by by words that someone else had said
much less of words that a girl has said
to you
you'd be mocked ruthlessly
then you're going to suffer real trauma
that that's that's the kind of social
sin
in going around saying i was traumatized
by those words you said to me
that would stay with you forever
you know if you said that in third grade
10 years later people would still be
talking about it making fun of you for
it
but this is how bullying works now
this is the this is the
the power of victimhood
the bully
asserts his power by affecting
powerlessness
by claiming that he is the one who is
traumatized
while he at least tries to cause trauma
to other people
i would say that's that's real trauma
when you
when you have the the internet lynch mob
coming after you you lose your job and
everything else
and i say all this knowing by the way
that
this this woman um
i'm going to assume a pretty good chance
that she is
a leftist herself given where just based
on where she lives alone
and so you might say this is another
example of the left eating its own
perhaps so
but it's still a problem because it's
yet again the bully
asserting the power of victimhood
it's just not possible to have a
functioning society this way
it was one thing when the strong used to
subjugate the weak by imposing their
strength now they subjugate the weak by
pretending to be weaker
which in the end we find out
is a
much worse situation
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
now a quick word from ziprecruiter you
know there are some things in life that
i like to pick for myself so i know i've
got the one that's best for me like cuts
of steak mattresses bottles of wine
i read bottles of wine on here but
honestly actually that's one i don't
know anything about wine i just i just
choose the second cheapest one i figure
it's best than it's a little better than
the worst type of wine
but other things you know you want to
pick it for yourself and what if you
could do the same for hiring choose your
ideal candidate before they even apply
that's where zip recruiters invite to
apply comes in it gives you as the
hiring manager the power to pick your
favorites from top candidates and right
now you could try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com walsh how does invite
to apply work well when you post a job
on zip recruiter they send you the most
qualified people for the job then you
can easily review the candidates and
invite your top choices to apply for
your job
um and it's as simple as that and what
that means is that you have more say in
this process of hiring people for your
position which you should because this
is your company and zip recruiter just
makes that so much easier you can see
for yourself just go to this exclusive
web address zipruter.com
walsh walsh to try zip recruiter for
free that's ziprecruiter.com
walsh ziprecruiter the smartest way to
hire
so i shared with you on friday
this loudoun county rally we've got
coming up
on september 28th that's uh tomorrow
we're gonna be in in loudoun county uh
at uh 4 p.m in ashburn virginia right
outside of the uh the school board
building
and
you know i shared with you how they
changed the rules at the last minute i'm
sure it was entirely coincidental
i had announced my plans to come speak
at the well i'm going to speak at the
rally they can't stop that from
happening that's all that was always
going to happen
um but also i was going to go to go in
and speak to and deliver some thoughts
to the actual school board and they
started changing they started changing
things they uh they shortened the
speaking time to a minute so they did
that they also moved up the speaking
time we you know so that it so that it
would so that it would overlap with the
rally so we had to push the rally back
to four clicks on doing five o'clock uh
so they did all that that was expected
and then at the very last minute they
said oh you know what we've uh we've
just decided a new rule here where you
have to be a resident of loudoun county
in order to speak at the loudoun county
school board meeting
uh and you have to prove your residence
with an id or a lease agreement or
you know mortgage statement or utility
bill or something
um
now
we we know why they made this change
but you have to think about they're
trying to exclude me okay it's that's
pretty clear
unless this all this is one big
coincidence but think about who else
they've excluded by the way
and with a rule like this this means
that um if you're a grandparent
uncle aunt you know relative of a child
in the school district
and you want to speak on their behalf
because as a family member you're
concerned about what's happening you
can't speak you're excluded
not to mention as we reviewed last week
all of these
schools get federal funding
which means that all of us in the
country are funding or personally
funding every single school
uh we all have a stake in it
all of our money is attending all of
these schools which means that we should
have a say
so anyway as they made this um this
coincidental change to require for this
meeting people to be residents
i also
and this is really incidental and just
it's really is a coincidence
and i i'd actually been thinking about
this for a while that um i would love to
have a place in loudoun county i've been
thinking about this
and i finally decided to pull the
trigger last week you know right after
loudoun county made their announcement
and so now i'm going to be leasing
a home in loudoun county i i did find
um a a homeowner there property owner
who was willing to give me a very
competitive rate
and so i'm very excited that now i and
i'll have the lease agreement which i
will present
while i'm walking into the school board
meeting tomorrow so i'm very excited
about that i am a virginia resident i'm
really excited
i'm a proud virginian
um
and i couldn't be happier about that so
i'll see you at the school board meeting
tomorrow
all right let's start with this
liz cheney was
she of course is
the democrats and the media's favorite
republican and we'll see why here she
was being interviewed on 60 minutes
and they st they got into the issue you
know into social issues cultural issues
and here's what liz cheney had to say
your sister's gay she's married she has
children
and in 2013
you came out against same-sex marriage
while your father went the other way
and it was looked upon as courageous
when he did that
how do you defend what you did i was
wrong
i was wrong uh i love my sister very
much
uh i uh uh love uh her family very much
uh and uh
and and i was wrong
it's a it's a very personal issue
and very personal for my family
i
believe that my dad was right
and my sister and i have had that
conversation
well
i was not expecting
you
that
this this is an issue that um
we have to recognize uh you know as as
human beings that
we need to work against discrimination
uh of all kinds
uh in our country in our state
we were at an event a few nights ago and
and there was a young woman who said she
doesn't feel safe
sometimes
because she's transgender
and nobody should feel unsafe freedom
means freedom for everybody
okay none of that meant anything at all
uh
it did sound like she said human beings
like a green bean that's beside the
point but
uh none of that that's just far left
claptrap is all that is
i just don't believe
starting with the issue of of same-sex
marriage
you'll notice she wasn't she says oh i
was wrong about that
i've changed my mind
there's this follow-up question that
amazingly you never hear in the media
but you think it'd be any normal
person's follow-up which is oh why
why did you change your mind about this
why did you initially believe
that marriage is between a man and woman
and what made you change your mind
and
what do you think marriage is now so you
believed marriage is a is an institution
which by definition
because that was always
the argument for the advocates of quote
unquote traditional marriage
the argument was never
that um it should be illegal for gay men
to get married or for lesbians to get
married that was never the argument
the argument is that marriage is a
particular thing it has a definition it
serves a certain function
in society and that is the function that
the function is supposed to be to serve
as the basis for
uh the family
and the family itself is the is the
cornerstone of society of of human
civilization
of the civilization of all human beings
um
that was the argument
you know it's not that
gay people should be prevented from
getting married
is that they can't
because marriage isn't that
that's not what marriage is
marriage is
it has a few defining features one of
them is that it is a fundamentally
in-principle
procreative union
okay there are couples who can't
conceive because of
because of illness or or birth defect or
whatever
but that does not
change
what marriage is in principle
it just doesn't change the fact that the
heterosexual union is in principle
um
a pro-creative union
so that was the argument um and you know
i i think was a pretty good argument
i still stand by that argument
personally
and you know unlike people like liz
cheney and so many other alleged
conservatives and republicans
i feel better
i feel even more short
of the arguments i made defending
quote-unquote traditional marriage years
ago today than i did even then
what we've seen happen in the
intervening years has only reinforced
my belief
in what marriage actually is
and part of that is because we've seen
exactly the slippery slope that we
predicted
has played out
by what would happen in society
especially with the institution of
marriage when you get rid of this of
this definition
so that has reinforced my views but also
because
here we are years later
when the pro-gay marriage side has has
won the argument they've certainly won
the argument um in society anyway
there's no doubt about that they've won
it culturally
but years later they still haven't told
us
what marriage is now
all they said was
oh no it's not a procreative union
between man and woman
and so we've been waiting around to find
out okay uh what then what is it now
what what is it exactly what is marriage
why do we have it why do we need it
and and so who who should be included in
it
we know you think gay couples anybody
else
and if we are now limiting this to
you know um heterosexual
adult single couples you know two people
and now and we've expanded it also to be
gay couples can we expand it beyond that
if not why not
what is it
they've never come up with an
answer because there isn't one
if marriage is not the foundation for
the family if it's not a procreative
union between between man and woman then
it's then it's not anything there's
there's no reason to redefine it it's
just nothing
then it's just
people that have decided that they want
to live with each other okay
there's no reason to call that anything
special there's no reason to treat it
especially
there's no reason to put any limitations
on it whatsoever
you know that's
that's what we had been saying
back before gay marriage became the law
of the land and
that argument has been proven correct
so that's what i would say about
i would love to hear from liz cheney or
any of these other republicans that have
had a change of heart why they had the
change of heart
they thought marriage was a particular
thing
10 years ago they don't think it's that
thing anymore why and what would they
say it is now
we don't get that answer
and then she also throws in the the
transgender bit as well
and
why is this really happening what's the
real answer if you were to get her real
answer if you were to ask and get the
real answer
the real answer is that she never had
any opinion about marriage she doesn't
care about that
she doesn't care about any of these
issues
she's a politician saying what she
thinks she needs to say that of course
is the real and sort of boring answer
but that's the fact
and so she'll adopt
the most far-left positions that she
needs to and now she's also doing it
with uh transgenderism as well wasn't
even asked about that throws that in
also
um and if you want to understand how how
deep the rot goes in the republican
party
so that's liz cheney for you
who is a leftist
and that's my issue with her a lot of
republicans a lot of conservatives don't
like her because she doesn't like trump
i don't really care about that i don't
think people are defined based on their
opinion of a guy i don't care who the
guy is
and that includes donald trump i'm not
defining anyone
or making any sweeping judgments about
them based on their opinion of a guy
especially a politician
i mean i'm sympathetic to anyone who
hates a politician i don't care who the
politician is
there are good reasons to hate every
single one of them
so that's not my problem my problem is
that she's a leftist
my problem is what you just heard in
that one minute clip there
so she's she's a persona non grata in
the republican party
uh she gets kicked out of her position
of
leadership and in her place goes elise
stefanik
who has the endorsement of donald trump
and is elise stephanic any better
no stefanik voted for the equality act
two years ago
the equality act which would impose
among other things the trans agenda on a
federal level across the entire country
i mean open up every single bathroom
sports team locker room all of it across
the country federally
it would erase religious liberty it
would be the final erasure of that's out
the window
not to mention basic truth biology
common sense all of that's out the
window from the equality act i mean this
is
uh i think it would be an exaggeration
to say the most radically far-left piece
of legislation ever written is the
equality act and elise stephanik voted
for it
and she has the endorsement of donald
trump but she and she's the one who
replaces liz cheney
and conservatives are sad there's plenty
of conservatives so good good we got
stefanik in there instead of that
dastardly liz cheney she's worse
the only difference is that she pretends
to like trump
yet another reason why we can't let
you know when we're deciding who the
leaders of the conservative movement are
going to be
who the leaders of the republican party
are going to be
we can't let donald trump be the
centerpiece of that
it can't be that we're deciding it based
on what what these people say about this
guy donald trump
because if you decide it based on that
you end up with a person in leadership
who voted for the equality act but just
so happens to
say nice things about trump
it's a total disaster i mean the rot is
is
goes all the way to the core goes down
to the roots of the republican party
i don't think there's any salvaging it
probably
all right um
let's move on some
clips over on cnn that we got to play uh
i'm look i'm no economics expert you
know that so maybe i'm the one who's
clueless here it's possible
but i want you to listen to this
washington post reporter on cnn with
brian stelter
and you tell me if this makes um
any sense at all but in fact the bill
itself will not cost 3.5 trillion
dollars in the sense that it will be
entirely or at least partly paid for so
the actual cost in terms of deficits
will be smaller than that perhaps even
zero although i think that's unlikely
and it's not even um you know fully
spending it's not really right to call
it a 3.5 trillion dollar spending bill
because there's probably about a
trillion dollars of tax cuts in it too
uh what
so she's talking about the 3.5 trillion
dollar spending bill
and she says that it's not really
spending
because it won't be
paid with debt it's gonna it's all gonna
be paid for
that's not actually true but let's leave
that totally to the side
her argument is that if you if you
buy something
and pay for it up front
it's free
that's what she just said this is a
washington post reporter on cnn of
course there's no follow-up on that she
wasn't challenged
stelter didn't
didn't stop and say well wait a second
what
so what she's saying is that if you go
to costco and you buy one of their
tvs
for a drastically reduced price you know
and you and you pay with cash up or you
pay with a debit card up front
then it's free
um i bought this tv on my debit card for
600 therefore the tv was free
what can you say about that that makes
that's just not
i i don't i don't even have to be in at
an economics 101 level to know
that's this isn't this isn't economics
at all this is basic logic here
that's not how it works if you paid for
it then you're paying for it
if it's a 3.5 trillion dollar spending
bill then that's how much money it costs
even if it doesn't add to the uh
to the deficit at all which of course it
will
let's pray a little bit more from brian
stelter because why not he also had
nicole hannah jones on
um and uh he asks her you know he's
throwing some real hard balls at her
asking her some tough questions let's
listen to that
but is this just the white lash in
another form nicole just you know some
white americans afraid to deal with the
reality so they don't want to hear it so
they try to ban it and then someday
their kids are going to laugh it off
i mean i i don't know i i think that
this is a a particularly dangerous
moment because there's one thing to
uh have right wing media saying they
don't just they don't like the 1619
project they don't agree with the 1619
project but it's quite something else to
have uh politicians from state
legislators down to school boards
actually making uh prohibitions against
teaching a work of american journalism
or really any of these other texts the
fact that we are all talking about this
this fake controversy called critical
race theory really speaks to how
successful uh the public uh propaganda
campaign has been i don't think it's
just about you know scared white parents
it's about a politician savvy sadly
stoking racial resentment and response i
think to the global protest last year um
in order to divide americans from each
other
uh first of all pet peeve here
i hate it when we change words like this
in in a totally unnecessary way so he
says is this a white lash against the
1619 project
what do you need why why do you have to
put white in there
do you think the real the original word
is blacklash
white is not the opposite of it's
backlash and white is not the opposite
of back
why can't it just be a backlash from
white people
white lash
so you've got white lash and black lash
is what's going on i guess
um
and then and then of course everything
she said about the 1690 project is is
nonsense but this is a good example
of uh of what the left does and there
it's very
effective where they take something that
at the very least you'd think they'd
have to admit it's controversial
they're trying to take crt critical race
theory
these radical ideas of race
about race i idea you know they they say
that these ideas oh they're only in the
higher academic and this these are just
theories that people are batting around
in law school and all that kind of stuff
um
and that used to be the case
these used to be ideas and theories
that uh
you had to go into university and and
find them
and involve yourself in these subjects
in order to encounter them
that used to be true
but it's not anymore because it's
filtering on down
into not just grade school but into
every facet of society
and this is a
an intentional this is not organic this
is an intentional thing that is
happening it's being engineered
there are people advocating for it
saying let's take these ideas about race
and let's
inject them into every corner of society
especially into grade schools
now at the very least you would think
that the people who are advocating this
would have to admit
that this look this is a radical change
we're doing
we know that this is this is a dramatic
shift we understand that it's
controversial but here's our argument
for it here's why we want to do it
we know it might be a little bit
startling but here's why we want to do
it
they're not doing that
they make the radical shift
they impose it on us
they don't really give a choice
and then as soon as it's done
they act like you're the crazy one
you're the radical one for for objecting
they're not going to admit that their
radicalism is radicalism at all
it's always the people objecting who are
the radicals
one other clip to play this is uh joe
biden on friday
keeping the
the whip gate going
but he actually takes it one step
further
we heard the lie about how border patrol
agents were whipping people
whipping haitian immigrants that was a
total lie it didn't happen it never
happened
he goes further than that even let's
listen to what he says
you said on the campaign trail that you
were going to restore the moral standing
of the u.s that you were going to
immediately end trump's assault on the
dignity of immigrant communities given
what we saw at the border this week have
you failed in that promise and this is
happening under your watch do you take
responsibility for the chaos that's
unfolding of course i take
responsibility i'm president but i was
horrible what to see as you saw to see
people treat it like they did horses
really running over people being
strapped it's outrageous i promise you
those people will pay
they will be an investigation underway
now and there will be consequences
there will be consequences it's an
embarrassment but it's beyond an
embarrassment it's dangerous it's wrong
it sends the wrong message around the
world or sends the wrong message at home
it's simply not who we are
yeah you're right that's not who we are
because that didn't happen i don't know
what being strapped means people being
strapped
is that an expression from his childhood
in 1832 i don't know
but horses running people over that that
wasn't even a part of the original
talking point
he added that one in
so the border patrol agents are down
there
running the haitian immigrants over with
their horses galloping through
running them down
trampling them into the dust that's what
he's telling us now he just added that
in there
and once again no follow-up from the
media nobody's saying wait they ran them
over with horses you say where did that
happen
that's that's an interesting detail
it doesn't matter they just simply make
things up makes no difference
the border patrol just down there
running over with horses
there was one guy he jumped off the
horse he picked up a haitian immigrant
body slammed him
this is not who we are
uh no no relation to the truth
whatsoever and no concern with the truth
um
finally
here's a headline from the daily mail
that i thought was interesting it says
why are so many suffering dreadful
coveted symptoms but still testing
negative
sarah vine was convinced she had it but
countless tests said otherwise
and she's far from alone so what is
going on
now reading a little bit here i don't
know who sarah vine is maybe we'll find
out
a nasty dry cough sniffle sniffles and a
thumping headache burning muscle pain
and if you didn't feel miserable enough
everything you eat tastes like dust it's
a list of symptoms that british the
british public have become all too
familiar with over the past 18 months
classic coveted or is it
a fortnight ago mail on sunday columnist
sarah vine that's what i love about
british media by the way they use they
use terms like fortnite they just drop
that in there
with no explanation
of course every american reader goes
what's a fortnight again how many nights
ago is that four
i don't think so a fortnight ago male on
sunday columnist sarah vine wrote about
how she had been battling exactly this
combination of ailments but multiple
tests both the gold standard pcr and
rapid lateral flows had come back
negative
speaking on our medical minefield
podcast the 54 year old mother of two
described the phenomenon as spooky
she said quote it's so very weird i
don't really get ill and when i do it
doesn't tend to stop me doing things but
this really stopped me in my tracks and
it seems sarah isn't alone her original
revelation triggered a deluge of letters
from readers suffering in the same way
and equally desperate for answers about
their mystery illness
some like 23 year old molly whitaker
have been suffering like sarah with
lingering symptoms it started with a
continuous cough loss of taste and smell
and a slight temperature
i've done multiple
cova tests pcr all negative i'm now
three weeks later on a course of
antibiotics but they're not helping
another reader marie morgan uh wrote
i've never felt so ill in my life for
three weeks i experienced high
temperatures prolonged bouts of deep
cold and shivering but at night the
sweats were so bad i completely soaked
two or three times
uh and then on and on and on okay
all of these people mostly women
complaining of these symptoms
and they're saying it's spooky it's
weird
they have these coveted symptoms but the
tests come back negative what we're
meant to take from this
is that um
the covet is far more widespread than
we're even being told
and you know even if the tests come back
negative you probably still have it
i think that's the the implication here
at least that's what we're supposed to
take away from
i have another theory though
let me see if i can clear this up
this spooky mystery
um here it is
that covid symptoms
are also the symptoms for the common
cold
and for the flu
and for literally dozens of other
viruses
i mean
probably
any virus you can name actually
causes at least some of the coveted
symptoms
that's because covid's symptoms are
extremely broad
okay so when you get um a headache and
you have a stuffy nose
or you have a cough
those aren't coveted symptoms those are
just illness symptoms
not
maybe i can simplify it and summarize it
and i'll do it this way
not everything is covered
it may shock you to learn that
there are still lots of other illnesses
out there and it's not all coveted
we now live for for a world where we're
trying to get rid of binaries
uh at least in some areas it's
interesting that now we live in this
binary where
um
you know
if you're if you're sick it's you either
have covid or you have coveted like
symptoms and those are the only two
options
it's kind of amazing this is an entire
article
in a major publication talking about how
people with the how it's spooky that
some women have a cold
ooh spooky
all right let's uh move on now to
reading the
rocking comments dot and flannel shirts
without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
all right um
this is from ultra galaxyify
on the subject of culture i agree with
matt on everything except for one thing
a culture can only be destroyed when the
people are either killed off or
completely forget it the destroyed
monuments and textbooks that tell us our
history are certainly important in
preserving our past which is an
important component of any culture but
it won't outright kill it the only way
to do that is to kill brainwash the
people which the far left is trying like
hell to do especially the latter uh yeah
the destroying the monuments doesn't
that's not what what um
kills the culture
that in and of itself doesn't erase
history
um that is speaking of symptoms that's a
that's a symptom of the culture being
destroyed
and being replaced by
not a new culture but an anti-culture
that's also brings us back to the issue
of
marriage get rid of the definition of
marriage
but don't replace it with a new one it's
not like we have now a new idea about
marriage instead we just marriage is
nothing we don't have any ideas about it
vanessa says the public school is
becoming a brave new world education
yeah i i think that's the right more
more than a 1984 orwellian
thing i think the public school and our
culture in general more closely
resembles a brave new world
um i've always thought that huxley got
nailed it a little bit better than
orwell did
mike says pretty sure i saw matt
screaming and running out of an auto
parts store the other day couldn't catch
him to get an autograph sweet daddy
walsh is fast it's true this happens to
me all the time
which is why
i always have my phone on me so i can go
to rockauto.com
uh lone star carl says i'd forgive matt
for leaving a shopping cart out but i
will burn my sbg shirt if i catch him
jogging outside with a mask on
well you would never see that but if you
did
you have my permission to walk up to me
and smack me right in the face
in fact you have my permission to do
that to anyone wearing a mask while
jogging outside
just kidding
sort of
helena says yesterday was my sister's
birthday and she who's not a member of
spg said to me you have to explain the
sweet baby gang to me because it's my
birthday so i tried and it didn't go so
well
and this is why i keep i i hear this
from people all the time
they tell me about the awkward
situations they've been put in because
they tried to explain the the sweet baby
gang we don't explain it
we don't talk about it it just is and we
leave it be that's all
um
and don smith says in my school bethesda
high school in maryland i'm sometimes
the only one who stands for the pledge
of allegiance it's terrible
uh
yeah i i i hear this a lot from kids now
i mean this is a this is another
difference between now when i now i can
remember going to school in the pledge
in some classes there'd be a couple of
kids who didn't stand for it
and usually was an issue because the
teachers would say you got to stand for
the pledge and there's there would be
this tension
but now from what i'm hearing
increasingly
it's com it's completely flipped
and you've got a couple that maybe stand
for the pledge and everybody else sits
which is obviously not a good sign about
our culture and i say that even though
you know i'm i'm an
advocate for the pledge because of what
it represents
and having kids
being in a country
where most kids won't even stand for it
that's not a good sign
but in a perfect world i wish that we
could have a conversation about the
pledge and the words that it actually
contains because you know i i have been
it seems almost academic now but i'm
sort of i've been a critic of of the way
that the pledge is written only because
there's the one word in the pledge um
indivisible
right
the the idea this that the country is
indivisible
that's actually not true
and it's important to note that it's not
true the country is divisible the states
are not bound together forever eternally
um they are supposed to
we are supposed to have states rights
and i believe you should have the right
in a union if it's a real union you
should have the right to terminate it if
you want to
if the people of the state choose that
so i'm not a fan of the indivisible line
there but we're not at a point where we
can even have a conversation like that
um
when most people won't stand and you
know i i think the kids who aren't
standing it's not because they're
advocates of states rights i think i
could probably assume that the good news
is that this new text this new uh texas
law banning abortion after six weeks
will save a lot of lives it's also
driving the left insane which is kind of
fun to watch
but um
the other part of this the bad news
sometimes is that uh for for some people
when this topic of abortion comes up
even people who are pro-life they're not
always prepared to engage with it and
engage with the arguments and represent
their side well which is why
uh the new book what to say when the
complete new guide to discussing
abortion was written and you got to
check it out it's also why i chose to
write the forward for the book because i
found it very useful even as someone who
talks about these issues every single
day i've argued with many people about
it i still found the book to be very
useful since its release it has been
already a number one amazon new release
and a number two amazon bestseller and
it's already on its second printing it's
an easy book to use
tells you what to say what not to say
and it's proven arguments have worked
with everybody including uh former work
people who've worked in the abortion
industry including planned parenthood
workers have found these arguments
compelling and changed their ways and
left that culture of death that industry
of death so you know
that this book has something for you so
go to amazon or get it directly from 40
days for life at 40daysforlife.com
and you know you deserve to wake up to
the facts which is why we started our
newest podcast morning liar which has
been topping the apple and spotify
charts since its recent release it's the
only daily news podcast that values your
time and the truth and while we're
working overtime to bring you the news
you need to know we need your help to
keep the facts trending towards number
one so subscribe and start listening now
to morningwire applespotify or wherever
you listen to podcasts and leave a five
star review if you like what you hear
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know if you're still a fan of any
hollywood film franchise now would be a
good time to abandon ship i mean the
problem with hollywood franchises is
first of all
almost all of them are lifeless and
redundant as they exist only to
perpetuate and profit off of the brand
of course all movies are supposed to
make money but the difference is that
franchises like marvel and star wars and
others
have no purpose beyond that the next
installment in the series doesn't come
into being because someone really wants
to tell the story
and convinces a studio to sign on
rather the next installment is the
result of people sitting around in a
room and saying you know we need to ring
another 90 minutes out of this anyone
got any ideas
as far as i'm concerned that's reason
enough to stop watching these glorified
cash grabs
the other is that every single one of
them
has gone or will go
woke
in fact at this point someone somewhat
incredibly
wokification comes before profitability
on a studio's list of concerns
the films exist to keep the brand
relevant and make money off of them yes
that's the motivation which spurs them
into being that's why they're conceived
but the first priority upon conception
is to make sure that the script is
orthodox and in keeping with the
prevailing doctrines of the day
they'll actually sacrifice some of the
profits in order to do this
so in summary before you sit down to
watch any new installment in any
hollywood franchise
you know from the start that it will be
cynical leftwing agitprop which was made
only to increase the studio's profits
and brand awareness and to propagate
deranged leftist values
any entertainment value outside of all
that will be an accidental byproduct
and of course if you wish to be
entertained
you must first assume the mentality of a
person with room temperature iq and no
standards or self-respect
and this mental maneuver proves to be
pretty easy for some people probably
because they don't have to assume that
mentality so much as they already have
it going in
but these are all just things to keep in
mind as the new james bond movie is set
to release next week i have no specific
information confirming this but i can
already guarantee
that it will be the wokest james bond
film in the history of the franchise
it couldn't exist in the year 2021 if it
weren't
there have been some indications though
like the actress who plays the new bond
girl
announced that her character will be the
most badass bond girl in history
of course nobody watches james bond
hoping to see a badass bond girl they
want james bond to be badass the bond
girl is supposed to be pretty that's
really her only job at least it was her
only job back before wokeness became the
overriding priority indeed the push now
is to turn the entire bond franchise
into a girl power vehicle
lately lately the cries have been
deafening from the media anyway not so
much from the movie going public for a
female james bond
with daniel craig leaving the role after
this next film
it seems inevitable that the character
will finally undergo this gender
transition and many outlets have been
publishing articles listing helpful
suggestions for which actress might be
suitable to fill james bond's shoes
vogue for example says that um kate
blanchette victoria victoria beckham or
emily blunt
might be perfect for the role
yes because when i think of someone who
might be credibly portrayed as a
kick-ass action hero who can beat up a
room full of bad guys and then drive
away in their fancy sports car and make
it to the villain's lair just in time to
vanquish him and foil his dastardly plot
when i think about that
my mind immediately turns to
kate blanchette
but this is the problem with female
action heroes in general
for all i know
daniel craig and keanu reeves and the
rock and even liam neeson
might be big softies who punch like
girls in real life but they have at
least a screen presence
and an aura
that makes them seem like the kinds of
guys you wouldn't want to mess with
does any female actress really have that
quality
charlie starring played an elite spy and
assassin in the movie atomic blonde a
few years ago
would anyone actually be worried if
charlize theron was mad at them in real
life
is anyone going to run away and say i
hope charlize theron doesn't beat me up
does charlize theron have any natural
intimidation factor
does gal gadot does brie larson
see this is the problem
most female action
movies come with this natural
silliness factor
and there's a certain silliness to all
action films but the ones that reeves
and neeson and craig starr and tend to
also reach sometimes successfully
sometimes not for a certain dark and
gritty and serious tone
but you can't often do that with the
female-led films they all have to be
cartoons in the end because when it
comes down to it you're still watching a
hot 100 pounds supermodel do her best
jason statham impression and it's just
kind of funny
daniel craig was asked this question
about whether there should be a female
james bond
and he said no
but he made sure to qualify his answer
by saying that there ought to be new
franchises just as good as james bond
and similar to james bond built around
female action stars he argues that women
deserve their own heroes rather than
constantly appropriating already
existing male heroes
and he's on the right track with that
answer but he's missing something
and even if he's not missing this he
would never say it out loud anyway
and it's this
yes there should be films about female
heroes
yes they should have their own films
rather than simply taking male
characters and giving them sex
reassignments
but these women heroes
should also be heroic
in womanly ways
okay rather than having female
protagonists who are heroically
masculine
why not female protagonists who are
heroically feminine
not all heroism involves beating people
up and driving cars really fast in fact
in real life the vast majority of heroic
acts don't include any of that
unfortunately
i have known many heroic women in my
life
and none of them so far as i know
have ever thrown a punch at all which is
good because they probably break their
wrists if they did
physical courage is but one type
there's also moral courage
emotional courage
intellectual courage and all of these
types of courage come wrapped up in what
i would call maternal courage
a good mother like my wife for example
shows courage every day even though she
may go her whole life and never have to
drop kick any assassin or defuse any
bomb
now i realize that it's harder to make a
compelling film
that showcases the quieter less physical
forms of courage
but these are the very kinds of courage
that society looks to women to exhibit
and provide
which means that if we really want
women represented on screen as female
heroes
and not merely as female heroes
pretending to be male heroes
then it might be time to start investing
in scripts and stories
that have a little more depth and a
little more nuance
and that's why before she even exists
i have to today cancel
the female james bond or jane bond or
whatever we're going to call her
and that'll do it for us today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
house democrats vote to legalize
abortion nationwide up until the moment
of birth house republicans vote to make
women sign up for the draft and the
biden administration admits that it has
released at least ten thousand illegal
aliens into the country just last week
check it out on the michael knowles show